sentidos
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a los observadores de
france 24 hoy les traemos una edición
especial que nos lleva al centro de malí
donde hemos estado investigando la
muerte de varios hombres que
presuntamente fueron asesinados por
militares los hechos ocurrieron en la
aldea tenía hugo durante una ofensiva
del ejército maliense contra
combatientes yihadistas en la región de
nord y los habitantes afirman que las
víctimas eran civiles que iban al
mercado
entonces qué pasó realmente
investigamos utilizando fuentes en
líneas de libre acceso como imágenes de
satélite o vídeos aficionados que fueron
publicados en las redes sociales también
entramos en contacto con un testigo de
los hechos los resultados de esta
investigación los tiene toma educ
si se ve
y yo todavía hay muchas casas quemadas
hacia el exterior
la aldea parcialmente quemada que
muestra este hombre es ni a hugo ubicada
en la región de norte en mali
todo comenzó cuando fue publicado este
vídeo en twitter el pasado 9 de enero
estaba acompañado de un mensaje la cara
de nya hugo tras el paso de la fama las
fuerzas armadas de malí en este país
circulan otros vídeos del hecho la
redacción de los observadores de france
24 recibió 8 vídeos a través de su
número de whatsapp en este vídeo
encontramos los mismos elementos aquí
vemos una carreta y un objeto amarillo
así que fueron grabados en el mismo
lugar y al mismo tiempo pudimos
encontrar a un habitante que presenció
en la escena por su seguridad
difuminamos su rostro y cambiamos su voz
lo llamaremos ya lo
tengo miedo tengo mucho miedo
según díaz lo todo comenzó el lunes 3 de
enero cuando unos hombres uniformados se
instalaron en las afueras de la
población
específicamente al este
eran soldados malienses militares
llegaron alrededor de las 5 alrededor de
las 5 de la tarde
vinieron que eran soldados valientes así
que no iban a hacer nada
al día siguiente ya lo oí una docena de
personas partieron hacia shofar por ser
el día de mercado pero diálogo y sus
acompañantes fueron detenidos a la
salida tenía jugo
y
nos detuvieran no nos pidieron nada
algunas personas tenían documentos de
identidad
los hombres dejaron que ya lo y los
otros siguieran su camino
fue el dios que me dio la oportunidad me
fui no me dijeron nada
cuando nuestro observador regresó del
mercado alrededor de la una de la tarde
encontraron cuatro cuerpos sin vida
y llegamos y descubrimos que estaban
muertos
fuimos a mirar y vimos que estaban
muertos y lo desataron los brazos detrás
de la espalda y les dispararon en la
cabeza
[Música]
según díaz los cuatro hombres asesinados
formaban parte del grupo que había sido
detenido previamente un comerciante dos
criadores y un habitante de la aldea
vecina y otros cuatro que siguen
desaparecidos en algunos de los vídeos
se puede ver los cuerpos de dos hombres
siendo desenterrados por los mismos
habitantes uno de los muertos todavía
tiene las manos atadas detrás de la
espalda
había gente sus familias decían que
llevaban dinero consigo
cuando los vimos miramos no tenían nada
no sabían
uno de los vídeos permite determinar el
lugar exacto donde fue grabada esta
escena comparando esta imagen de 'google
earth' encontramos estos dos muros y
este árbol hablamos con nuestro
observador mientras nos muestra y
describe el paisaje detrás de él
m
efectivamente los dos muros y el árbol
están ahí
vinieron y como se puede ver
el profesor
incendiaron el pueblo
graneros casas y motos los hombres
uniformados quemaron por completo una
zona del pueblo esta destrucción fue
detectada incluso desde el espacio por
la nasa en esta imagen se ven dos focos
de incendios detectados en y hugo el 4
de enero el día del atentado pero nada
el día anterior ni el día después para
nuestro observador no hay duda de que
los hombres armados que atacaron y a
hugo y sus habitantes eran soldados
malienses otras fuentes también acusan
al ejército maliense de ser el
responsable de estas acciones por su
parte la cúpula del ejército maliense
afirma que sus tropas si llevaron a cabo
una operación contra los yihadistas en
otra aldea muy cerca de día hugo el 4 de
enero intentamos comunicarnos con el
portavoz del ejército maliense para
tener su versión de los hechos pero no
obtuvimos respuesta alguna
publicaremos su declaración en nuestro
sitio web y la recibimos en algún
momento una ong local pidió que fuera
realizado una investigación las imágenes
aficionados como las obtenidas para esta
investigación son utilizadas cada vez
más como prueba para documentar los
abusos de los derechos humanos
así concluye esta investigación de los
observadores de france 24 si desean
denunciar hechos similares no duden en
ponerse en contacto con nuestra
redacción todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en sus pantallas
nos vemos en una próxima oportunidad
hasta entonces